the next talk of the day is fourier
principle component analysis pca
uh thanks prasad for the invitation um
and the introduction
uh so this is joint talk with naveen
goyal and santosh vampira
okay
uh
so i guess before i start there should
be a disclaimer that this these fourier
transforms are actually taken over rn so
if anyone wants to
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
describe a machine learning problem for
you
and then
unrelatedly more relatedly i'm going to
develop an efficient tensor
decomposition which will solve this
problem and in between there's going to
be a little bit of fourier analysis
some derivatives
a good time for the next 45 minutes
okay
so let's start with the learning problem
um so the learning problem is called
independent component analysis and this
is kind of a this is kind of a big deal
of machine learning statistics i'll give
a little more background in a little bit
but the problem goes as follows so you
start with a random vector s it's fully
independent so it's a product
distribution
and uh just as a caveat s none of the si
components are gaussian
and so what you see are not the s's but
you see some fixed linear combinations
of the s's so you see a s a is a fixed
matrix
just to normalize it we'll say that it's
a full row rank and all the columns a i
have unit none
and so what happens is that you see
independent samples of this form
and your goal is to compute a
so
uh
here's a picture that should describe
the situation more clearly you start off
with some type of product distribution
for s this is your random vector so you
can think of for example a uniform
distribution over a hypercube
get independent samples
from this distribution it's the green
points there
but unfortunately those are not the
points that you see
uh rather you see
a product a s
so the uniform just over hypercube
becomes some type of parallel
pipette
and
your goal is to recover that parallel
pipette that map a only from samples so
all you see are
no you only know that the s's are
independent and not gaussian
so yeah not
no distributional assumptions at all
otherwise
so
the way to think about this is that you
have m random variables and you're
taking linear measurements of them
and you want to recover
the measurement system
so
the way this problem crops up
is that it's a it's kind of used as a
general dimensionality reduction tool so
when you have some data you run pca that
doesn't work out so well you go to ica
and random projections
it's standard enough that it's in this
uh
i guess despite all the elements of
statistical learning um and that's what
that citation there is
uh recently it's gained traction in
these deep belief networks so if you've
been following new york times google has
been building these really uh big neural
nets and this is used to specify the
layers
actually though the problem has been
around for a long time in signal
processing um
it's called blind source separation
deconvolution or cocktail party problem
we're trying to resolve individual
sources from linear combination
uh there's a ton of literature on it and
so uh the standard
reference is hivarn at all
and even more practically and this is
actually going quite a ways from theory
it's used in finance biology and
apparently when you get an mri taken
they are they try to decompos
ica actually
okay
and just a little bit more background on
the problem
so the problem's been around since the
late 80s uh the first people to really
formalize it and pin it
pin that
problem were uten and herod
um and it really came into theoretical
computer science
through this paper freeze germ and kanan
in 96.
uh recently
as of i guess last year there have been
some provably good algorithms for it in
uh
important cases but not in full
generality
and of course there are tons of
heuristics tons of things that people do
in practice and signals processing
which are
don't have any provable guarantees
okay so let's talk a bit about the
standard approach to these independent
components problems
um standard approach one thing you could
do is to just try straight pca so you
take your data x you form the covariance
matrix
xx transpose and then you just look at
the eigenvectors and the hope is that
the eigenvectors will give you the
column
um so
one
that's one formulation another
formulation is to consider the second
moments this is essentially the same
thing
um
and this is just the usual principal
component analysis
now
the problem with this is that it works
it works okay
when all your eigenvalues of your
covariance matrix are degenerate so if
you have a degenerate subspace with the
same value
then you end up with mixing in the
eigenvectors right and this essentially
prevents you from recovering the columns
of a
this is more of a problem when you
consider the fact that one of the usual
things you do when you see data is that
you put an isotropic position so you
make all the eigenvalues one it's a
standard normalization and it pretty
much breaks your ability ability to use
pca
okay so pca is
defining a contrast function using the
second moments uh a very natural thing
to do is to just try higher moments
fourth moments are particularly nice
and what happens if you massage the
fourth moment a little bit is that you
end up with some type of tensor
decomposition that you're trying to comp
so the fourth moment um
is
best represented as a tensor so an array
in n by n by n by n dimensions
um
and in the independent components case
you end up
see uh the fourth moment tensor ends up
being just a sum of uh outer products of
rank ones
and if you could recover the rank ones
you would be done
now
this is a intensity composition is a
pretty hard problem in general
but in the particular case when all the
ajs are linearly independent
you can in fact assume that they're
orthonormal
then the local optima
of this tensor suffice so you have a
tensor you view it as a full linear form
you find the local optimum of this thing
on the sphere just like you do for
eigenvalues
cover the ajs this way
so this is really standard and has been
around since the 80s as well
but essentially what happens with all
these algorithms is that as i mentioned
on the previous slide you require the
columns of a to be linearly independent
which
pretty much means that a has to be full
rank and by n
which means that you can only deal with
a problem when you have as many
measurements as underlying variables
and what i mean by that is that the
dimension of x here lives in rn has to
be the same as a dimension of s
a fully determined case
a second standard assumption that people
make when they analyze these algorithms
is that each component of the vector s
differs from a gaussian in the fourth
moment so our gaussian's fourth moment
is three so your fourth moment is
bounded away from three by this quantity
delta
so
yes i guess the key point is that this
precludes the underdetermined case when
a is a fat matrix you're taking
relatively few measurements so x is a
smallish vector and s is uh lives in a
really big
okay
so
what we do in our paper is
we we make a good amount of progress on
the underdetermined case
so where a is fat
and we also are able to relax the
assumption that you're bounded away from
a gaussian moment in the uh in the
fourth moment
um and informally our main result is as
follows
that if you have an underdetermined
model
then in time which is polynomial
uh
and by polynomial i mean depends on
several parameters here uh you can
you can compute columns of a
you can recover a uh the key parameter
is uh this thing here
where's that pointy this thing here um
and what this is is as follows so you
look at each column of your matrix a
and you tensor it up with itself
some number of times
and you want these things to be linearly
independent
and the intuition for that i'll explain
in a little bit but
this essential this is sufficient
for what we want to do and we believe
it's necessary but we can't prove it
just
okay so that's our major result
yes
okay so you
for some
but
i mean your complexity also depends on
which moment it is right because it's
harder to sample for higher moments
oh why are you saying oh sorry um the
reason is if i have let's say s1 and s2
is gaussian and i take a linear
combination then it's still going to be
gaussian in any two directions i pick
right
so it's not it's not identifiable you
can't uniquely recover it
um it's okay if you just care about the
subspace of gaussians that's fine but
you can't do anything
um
uniquely
any other questions
okay so i keep talking about this
underdetermined thing let me explain it
a little bit more
so once again s lives in some
in rm where m is relatively large so we
have our uniform distribution over cube
as a product again
you you have independent samples there
uh the matrix a does two things first
thing it does is that it does uh
it turns for example this uniform
distribution into a parallel pipette
but
what happens afterwards is that you have
a projection
and so you lose tons of information
um
so i guess it's a little bit surprising
that you can you can solve the
underdetermined case at all
okay
what am i doing
okay so
huh it's kind of a lot of math on this
slide um it's not as nice as i thought
so our basic algorithm is actually
relatively easy
so what you do first is that you pick a
random vector u and this is going to be
a random fourier coefficient
of the overall distribution that you're
interested in
and for each point in your sample
x say
uh you just compute the fourier way so
exponential of i u transpose x um
so yeah i guess my fourier transforms
are going to be over rn and not over the
boolean hypercube say
um
what you do next is that you this gives
you the weights wx and we just normalize
it
with this denominator here it's not a
big deal
and then what you do is that you just
form the covariance matrix and you stick
these weights in in the obvious way so
that's what this is you have your normal
covariance matrix terms here
x xx transpose subtracting off the mean
and then you just stick in the weights
so this is essentially just a
re-weighted covariance matrix
and what you do then is that you just
compute the eigenvectors of this
re-weighted covariance matrix
um
and basically magically the eigenvectors
end up being precisely the columns of a
so this is like the basic scheme
this only works for the fully determined
case you have to do something quite a
bit more complicated for the
undetermined case
uh so this uh this algorithm is actually
uh based on an idea by eredo from like
the early 90s
but giving giving a
analysis of this is actually
a little bit non-trivial
so
the question is why does this possibly
work why does this throwing in fourier
way since your covariance matrix help
you at all
and uh basically it's this for a
differentiation multiplication
relationship
so
if you want
the uh fourier transform of a derivative
of a function
then in the fourier space it's just the
same thing as multiply
by your fourier variable so that's
actually the underlying thing that's
going on here
what we actually end up doing is that we
end up considering
the log of the fourier transform of the
distribution
so in which case if you take a few
derivatives that's what this d squared
is you end up with a hessian matrix
and that's actually exactly the hessian
matrix on the previous slide
and this hessian matrix has this
following form uh
on each side you end up with an a and an
a transpose
so this is looking good right this looks
like a usual diagonalization
and then the diagonalization the
diagonals
are um
these functions g
and what these g's are
they're the univariate derivatives of
the log of the fourier transform of each
individual s
i uh sj sorry
so
if everything were real here you would
just have a diagonal you know uh
time derive a transpose you diagonalize
you go home you're done everything works
great
so i guess the sticky point for this is
that this is actually a complex quantity
so this is not a normal matrix it's not
hermitian so you have to work a little
bit harder
uh yes that's actually critical you you
have to anti-concentrate the eigenvalues
so that you have spacings
yeah yeah that's essentially the reason
why it works um
it's a little bit tricky because in the
undetermined case the a here
there are dependencies now but i'll go
into that in a little bit
um
okay so that was that was sort of the
quick and easy version for the fully
determined case
for the underdetermined case you have to
do
quite a bit more work
um
and so these are the uh these are little
hammers that we're going to hit our
problem with
so once again we're going to look at the
log of the fourier transform of the
distribution over x
um
and what we're going to do is that we're
going to compute the uh derivative
tensor of the log of the fourier
transform
and so when you have a function that's
multivariate and you differentiate it
once you end up with a gradient vector
you differentiate it twice you end up
with
a hessian matrix differentiate it three
times you end up you end up with a
tensor so this is this is where the
tensor decomposition will come in
and actually because it's a derivative
it's a derivative function right so you
have a derivative tensor at each point
of space so it's actually a tensor field
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to evaluate the derivative at two
randomly chosen points
u and now so not in the fully determined
case we only needed one point u
um and then this will give us two
derivative tenses t u and t
and then we just perform a tense
decomposition on tu and tv
to obtain the matrix uh matrix a
so that's that's kind of the scheme
it's uh
b
this thing
no this is a derivative operator
uh uh this how many how many times you
have to take the derivative
um
this depends this depends on how
underdetermined you are right
essentially you have to take enough
derivatives so you have uh
enough degrees of freedom to deal with
the fact that you have m
um and random variables
okay so i keep talking about these
derivatives and uh i guess we can
actually compute them out explicitly
it's not
it's not so
painful
so let's start with a really really easy
case when your matrix a is just an
identity matrix so someone's literally
giving you the uh
giving you s
so we have our log of our fourier
transform and let's differentiate it so
there's
kind of a lot of math on this slide too
but uh the idea is really easy actually
so when you have a fourier transform and
these s's are fully independent i can
separate the uh fourier transform into
the product
right the product of each individual
uh
each individual guy here like this
and now when i take the log this product
becomes a sum
so
this
log of the fourier transform just
becomes the sum of the log of the
fourier transform of each particular si
now when i differentiate with respect to
the variable ui here
ui only appears in one fourier transform
that of si
and that means that i will only end up i
will end up with a term that depends
only
on u i when i differentiate with respect
to
so there are no u2's u3's et cetera here
the point is that when i differentiate
once
my derivative depends only
on the
variable i differentiated with respect
to
so basically uh i guess product
distributions play very well with the
four uh
ray transform this is like the same idea
when you try to prove a turn off bound
right
uh we're sorry
oh yeah sorry i uh i dropped off yeah
suddenly
my bad yeah it doesn't make any
difference just because they all pop out
sorry
okay so
each component of my first derivative
depends only
on the variable i differentiated with
respect to
so if i differentiate twice now and i
look at the hessian matrix all my off
diagonal terms are zero
okay
um and all my diagonal terms end up
being some nasty expression
i'm not really that interested in i'll
talk a little bit about that later
um
and if i keep going with general
derivatives what happens is that because
my second derivative is already diagonal
my general derivatives will also be
diagonal
and so and and by diagonal i mean in the
strongest sense for tensors so that only
the iii coordinate is non-zero and
everything else is zero
um
and so let me just reiterate this one
key point that the high derivatives are
represented by tensors but i get to have
one tensor per
u i evaluate at so there are there are
there's an infinite number of these
things to work with
i so choose
okay
now that was the really easy case when a
was the identity matrix what happens
when you use a which is not an identity
matrix
and this actually this is more general
than just the basis change this is
actually any matrix
we have to work much harder basically
but if you do it for the second one you
end up
with the as popping out on either side
and notice that the argument is
basically column j of
a
in a product with u
and uh so that's the second derivative
if you go for the
general derivatives now with the
matrix a
then you have to work still harder but
what you end up with is an outer product
decomposition where the d derivative is
the sum over
outer products
d outer products of the columns of a and
then some coefficient which i'm going to
call g again
it's g sub j sorry
and these coefficients are dependent
only
on
this a transpose u of j
so what i mean to say is that all your
derivative tenses independent of where
you choose to evaluate them have the
same outer product here
um and what you want to do in principle
is compute what the outer product
decomposition is
but we have an infinite number of tenses
to work with
uh it turns out we need only two
but let's uh take a look at what happens
if you only look at one of them
so if you look at only one derivative
tensor well actually you can forget
about derivatives you can just consider
a tensor of this form if someone gives
you a tensor of this form and asks you
to recover the ajs uh
when is this possible and
when is it computationally efficient
and basically the answer is never um it
can't be hard and i only know of one
class of tenses where this is actually
possible
okay and by one class of tenses i mean
when your tensor is of order greater
than three
when the order of your tensor is two
it's just the usual eigenvalue
decomposition here so this is reasonable
to do
when the order of your tensor is greater
or equal to 3 so it's an n by n by n
tensor or larger
and when your ajs are linearly
independent then you can do this tensor
power iteration
which is basically just the analog of
the matrix power iteration for computing
however if because of this condition
because the ajs have to be linearly
independent it implies that you can't
consider too many ajs
if if your if your tensor decomposition
here has too many
you can't you can't find them
just as an aside and this will be
important later uh
this is related besides earlier question
uh your lambda j's head better be
different here or else you're never
going to recover the ajs uniquely it
just forms
so
trying to decompose the tensor when you
only have
one tensor is going to be really hard
but we have an infinite number of these
tenses
and actually we can just use two so
let's pick some mu some lambdas and
let's say we have
two tenses with the same vectors in
their outer products
then what we're going to do
is that we're actually going to recover
the ajs from this pair here
and the
the uh the actual algorithmic technique
is that we're actually going to take
these tensors and we're going to flatten
them down
to a matrix
so you define some
map between say a fourth order tensor or
an m by n by n by n tensor and you just
turn into an n squared by n squared
matrix
so you'll end up with something like
this
uh you'll have the diagonal of the
coefficients and then on each side
you'll be conjugated by the vector of
the tensor powers the d over two powers
of the columns of a so basically what
happens is that you split half of these
factors and they go to the left and half
of these factors and they go to the
right here
so if you're given these two tenses and
you want to decompose it
the algorithm is
relatively simple
so okay i'll just explain this as
follows um
you flatten the tenses down to mu and m
lambda first and step one just make sure
that mu and m lambda are full rank
so we can start taking inverses
and then what you do is uh you take mu
and m lambda which are now full rank
because of the w's and you just multiply
mu with m lambda inverse
um and this gives you
another matrix m
and then all you have to do is you take
m and you compute the eigenvector
decomposition of it and once again m is
not normal it's not hermitian or unitary
anything nice uh so it has to be a
general eigenvector decomposition with
an inverse
and then you take these eigenvectors
say each column of p is called pi
and you basically stick it back into a
tensor and you extract the best rank one
component there
and for this you can use the tensor
power iteration because it's just one uh
it just has one component in the uh
rank one
um
in the ring one sum and then once you do
that you have to clean up you have to
make
all the extracted vectors real again
that's not really that interesting
so
yeah i guess the takeaway from this
slide and for most of this talk is that
you have two tenses with the same
vectors and they're out of product
decomposition you take one you squish
into a matrix you take the other you
squish into a matrix take its inverse
and then you diagonalize
that that's that's
the uh major idea
and so
uh
if you look at the actual theorem that
you can prove about these things
uh
as prasad said you need the uh the
coefficients to be different
from each other but once they're
different from each other and once your
ajs are not uh in the tensor space are
not
linearly dependent then you can go ahead
and recover the ajs up to whatever
accuracy you want in polynomial time
so yeah the point here is that
decomposition of one tensor is too high
decomposition of pairs of tenses
is relatively easy if you're careful
about it
okay so
this might be a little bit surprising
but the uh
the uh the basic idea is pretty easy so
we started with tenses t mu and t lambda
and we squish them down into matrices mu
and m lambda and let's pretend mu and m
lambda are full rank
uh if i do so then and i multiply mu by
the inverse of m lambda so then you get
basically six terms uh the first three
correspond to mu the last three
correspond to m lambda inverse
and uh because they share the same out
of product decomposition uh
i basically have two cancelling terms
here
and in that case uh
my diag i end up with uh
my vector of uh tensor powers of a
a diagonal matrix which corresponds to
mu j divided by lambda j
and then
uh an inverse here
of the tensor powers of a
so
if you look at it this is p d p inverse
and so these are the eigenvectors
so this is really easy if you're
interested in the exact case in the
robust case where there are
perturbations so you have m mu plus some
error and then m lambda plus some error
uh
diagonalizability becomes a bit of an
issue
and by which i mean the following
if i have a matrix a and i can write as
pdp invest
what happens
when i look at a plus perturbation
can i can i still write the same thing
um
and in particular what do i actually
need for diagonalizability
so one thing i need is i i clearly need
my eigenvector matrices to be invertible
otherwise i shouldn't be writing p
inverse anyway
but a characterization of
diagonalizability is when your minimal
polynomial has non-degenerate roots
now the minimal polynomial is not
something
i'm very good at working with
but a sufficient condition for
diagonalizability is that all your roots
uh by which i mean all your eigenvalues
are non-degenerate so once again this
comes back to precise question
uh my eigenvalues have to be well spaced
i want to be robust about this
so
when i take my matrix m and there's some
perturbation
um
when are the roots well spaced if the
eigenvalues of m are well spaced and in
the normal case you just apply this file
inequality no eigenvalue moves too much
uh because my eigenvalues are real
they're well ordered as well
um
and my my my eigenvalues move up most by
the spectral norm of my perturbation
so in the case when your matrix is not
normal not hermitian
there are kind of a couple of things
that you can try to do
one is the bower phi theorem
and what this says is that
every eigenvalue of your perturbed
matrix is close to some eigenvalue of
your original matrix
now the problem with this is that all my
eigenvalues of my pattern matrix could
in principle be close to a single
like lambda 1 of my original matrix so
this prevents you from getting any
decent type of spacing result
the other thing you there are some other
results but they essentially assume that
your perturbed matrix a plus e is
already diagonalizable which is exactly
what we're trying to prove so that's not
helpful at all
so one of the things we have to do is
that we have to prove sort of a
generalized vowel inequality
so when you have a diagonalizable matrix
and its eigenvalues are well spaced and
then you perturb it
um
then you can come up with a mapping
between the eigenvalues now which is
bijective here
and where the bijection doesn't change
your eigenvalue as much
so the proof of this is viral homotopia
argument uh if you know the gerschkorn
theorem there are some strong variants
of that
and you have to use something like that
okay so in terms of the analysis of the
tensor decomposition in the robust
setting uh you apply this inequality
um then you have to apply some
eigenvector perturbation bounds once
again because we're not normal we can't
use davis kahan's the sine theta theorem
we have to use more general things
uh we use a result of ibsen and
eisenstat
this means that your eigenvectors are
now close to the vector of the tense and
up ajs
you apply tensor power iteration that
step is robust two and then
so that's the tensor decomposition
that we developed for this
now the question is how do you use it to
solve the underdetermined case and uh
it's actually really easy so just as a
quick reminder under determined x equals
a s a is a fat matrix so you're taking
fewer measurements then there are
underlying random variables
so you pick two random vectors u and v
you form
these derivative tensors t u and t
and then you just run the tensor
decomposition on it
so that's that's our algorithm
okay so one thing i should mention
before we go over any further is how do
you actually estimate these derivatives
um
and because of this for a
differentiation multiplication
relationship
what you can do is you can just sit out
there ground out the derivatives using
the quotient rule
uh it's a little bit unpleasant
so
uh if i just look at the fourth
derivative tensor this is just one term
of it
um
there are products of all these
exponentials all these
polynomials uh
so actually there are something like 17
mod terms of this form
so it's not it's really not very
pleasant but the salient point is that
if you consider the number of
derivatives you're taking to be a
constant then you basically have
d to the d
um each one is really easy to estimate
empirically because as long as your
your moments are bounded these things
are bounded
um
so it's not a big deal it's just kind of
gross
okay so then
in the underdetermined ica setting we
end up with a similar theorem to what
you saw for tensor d
that you have dependencies on
how linearly independent the tensor
powers of your columns of a are
and you have a dependency on how much
your moments differ from a gaussian and
so i write [ __ ] there for cumulant
um and this is basically just a uh
it's a it's a polynomial of the moments
it's uh
it's not substantially different
okay
so
i've
a little bit of time left so i can talk
about how you actually prove this
so
yeah
it's uh
the overall scheme should be relatively
clear from what we are
what i said earlier so if you take a
derivative tensor at u you end up with
something of this form uh the the
diagonals are going to be the d
derivatives of the log of the fourier
transform of each variable
and so now we just have to show
by applying our previous tensor
decomposition theorem that the quotients
now are well spaced
between uh when you take a
u and the v
so if you want to show your quotient so
well spaced um
this is this is where the math actually
comes in
okay um so
what you do is that you take the d
derivative uh the diagonal terms and
your taylor series expand it
and
what you what you do is you truncate the
taylor series at where you know the
moment difference is
um this is only for sake of analysis you
don't actually have to know this while
running the algorithm
and so you have a remainder term here
from the taylor series uh but you know
the remainder term is bounded
uh and in fact small basically because
you know of the existence of one more
moment
um
and then so the scheme is this is a
finite degree polynomial we're going to
anti-concentrate that using a uh
polynomial integration inequality and
then we're just going to bound the tail
error and make it small relative to the
anti-concentration
so the tail arrow first like i said it's
just the dth derivative of a log of the
fourier transform
uh for the fourier transform i know that
uh
the derivative is less than the uh df
moment so that's meant to be a d then
not okay so what you do is you apply the
quotient rule you count the number of
terms you have it's not too big it's
like d to the d
and you just have a moment bound
so the taylor is really easy
uh the polynomial anti-concentration in
the finite polynomial part
you need something which
i mean it's essentially a univariate
polynomial anti-concentration quality
so
i guess the usual way of getting these
is through this cabaret right result
right
the problem with that is
we only know something about one
coefficient so that's why i'm talking
about monitors here the highest order
coefficient
and in fact the other coefficients could
be bounded you could have really big
gaps from gaussians at some other step
so and then you have to integrate this
lp
norm of the polynomial of your measure
it's a little bit tricky
um
but you can do much
you can do a similar thing uh using much
easier techniques
and there's the proof
but the picture is
much easier okay so let's say that i
have a uh
degree d polynomial then for any band
around any uh
around one for example and uh i can only
cross that band d times this is
basically because you need a sign change
in your polynomial cross back into the
band
um each band is of not too high width
because i know the polynomial has to
change at least a certain amount in any
interval and this is uh
i guess lower bounded by the chebyshev
polynomials
and then i just basically take the
product i have this many bands they're
this wide and the gaussian measure is at
most one over
sigma square root two pi right so that's
uh that's where the polynomial
anti-concentration bound
so
okay so once again we're not actually
anti-concentrating uh
a particular g we actually have to deal
with these
relatively unpleasant quotients you
basically truncate
uh
some probability tricks it's not it's
not
terribly interesting
um
but once again your spacings
surprisingly end up depending on the uh
on how linearly independent your tensor
powers
and so you you are you you prove that
any two anti-concentrate then you just
union bound basically
okay so that pretty much concludes
uh
the technical part
so you know now you have
anti-concentrated diagonals you just run
the tensor decomposition you're done
um
because we're using the fourier
transform over rn you can actually do
some additional nice things
one thing you can do is let's say that
you have a gaussian noise here an eta of
any gaussian which is independent of s
um
then you can actually remove it and
basically the way this works is that
uh this data is invariant under taking
fourier transforms because
gaussian
another
thing that you can do is that you can
prove
uh you can give a result for a gaussian
mixture model
so the way the gaussian mixture model
works is that there are k gaussians
uh someone's picked ahead of time and
when you see a sample you first pick a
gaussian
with weight wi
and then you pick a point from that
particular gaussian and so the goal is
to recover the parameters of the
gaussians and so we can do this for when
your number of gaussians is at most your
dimensionality
so uh i guess this is another proof of
the result by sue and kakad he said i
guess we can deal with gaussian noise
too
yes
hmm
sorry spherical gaussian's only at this
point
um that's
yeah so that's actually like the major
open problem here can you do anything
for non-spherical gaussians right
uh you probably have to do something
like the underdetermined
uh tensor
type techniques because there are just
too many parameters that you're trying
to learn that you're not going to get
from just a matrix right
right right sure
sure
um as far as open problems goes uh
there are some
generalizations of this independent
components model called independent
subspaces where
your random variables s are split into
subspaces which are independent but
within each within the particular
subspace it can have very complicated
dependencies
um
and this is uh this is really
this is really the thing that people use
in uh these deep
so it would be nice to be able to prove
something there
um a more
vague hand wavy question is
what is the relationship between our
method and kernel pca
uh
it looks a lot like it but it's not
quite the same thing because when you do
kind of pca you end up with a
so i think it looks similar but i'm not
sure what the connection is there
and of course the gaussian mixtures
okay and uh i think that's uh that's it
yeah if i take the real characteristic
function i better hope that all my um
all moments exist right
if i'm taking exponential of u transpose
x right if uh if x
has infinite moments
then life is going to get complicated
right
or because it's that only becomes a
phase factor at that point right if u
transpose x gets really really big i'm
just going around on the
on the uh
complex plane right
it's like the fourier transform always
exists but like the laplace transform
doesn't right
yeah yeah that's the other thing uh all
the previous ones well i guess
okay yeah we can deal with heavy tail
distributions is why you
take the
let's get complex
it